your stocks don't pay you every month
get investments that pay your month
between does not pay you every month is
not freedom it does not provide you with
financial freedom done this damn thing
you could ever buy in your life is a big
expensive luxury car America will become
a renter nation it will become
impossible more and more impossible and
more and more unnecessary for people to
buy homes than ever in my lifetime
what's that belief nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent inside you and I want you to find
it embrace it and use it to make a
difference now I started to mentor me
series to try to hang around people
who've done a lot more than us try to
learn from them try to embrace our
knowledge and hopefully some of their
mindsets beliefs seep into us to help us
become the best version of ourselves so
today we're gonna learn from one of the
best grant cardone on how and where to
invest mentor me grant
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one get the cash flow pay attention what
I'm telling you right now because I know
a lot of you out there thinking about
starting your own business or maybe
you're in transition
maybe you got a job you're trying to
figure out how to buy your first
apartment deal or your first
single-family house you're doing a flip
pay attention when I'm telling because
I'm gonna save you a lot of money and
I'll show you how to make a bunch of
money I took on this first job at twenty
nine started this job went out on my own
and man it would work but I was making
it took me about three years to match
the money I had been making so I was 32
years 31 years old maybe and I started
making the same kind of money that I was
making at that sales job and then I boom
I lit this baby up and I figured out how
to do the deal I'll save that for
another video how it took my business
started making about a million bucks a
year this is what I did with the money
and this this message really is for all
of you out there that have put some
money away
I was stacking money I was going out in
the marketplace I was working 300 days a
year on the road literally leave my home
I was living in Houston and I would
travel around the country 300 days of
the year I was only home 60 days a year
the rest of time I'm out pitching
pitching and pitching and it was work
and I knew one thing about this job that
I had this business that I owned if I
wasn't pitching it I wasn't making money
I was 31 32 years old and I was dying
didn't have a relationship couldn't have
kids couldn't get married couldn't stay
in a relationship because I was never
home I was out banging pushing shoving
hammer and hitting every day every week
discouragement disappointment score
discouragement disappointment score and
what I would do is I would sack that
money away now remember I'm working 300
out of 365 days a year
I can't spend money everywhere I'm going
I'm making money and I'm putting it away
but I didn't know what to put it into
started my second business with a
partner he starts making money so both
businesses start making some money and I
end up with a bunch of dough on the side
sitting in the bank dying you don't I
mean when money's dying when money's
dying that means it's not working it's
not growing it's not going anyplace
my uncle said to me one day son you need
to learn how to get your money to work
for you as hard as you work for it oh my
good good piece of advice you gotta need
you
can you tell me what to do he's like
well I buy these little single-family
home Section eight and I rent them to
people and the government gives me a
check and I'm like I don't want anything
to do with the government so I started
checking out real estate how can I own
real estate control real estate use the
cash I have in the bank to buy a piece
of real estate and have enough tenants
pay me a check every month I didn't do
it the way my uncle did it my uncle did
it one house at a time I did it a
hundred units at a time my first deal
was 38 units my second deal was 48 units
my third deal was to 90 units now we
don't even look at deals that said we
that size we look at deals 400 units 500
units now why am I telling you this and
what should you take away from this okay
my first real estate deal was one house
I bought one house I rented it and as
soon as they moved out I had problems I
had to sell the house just like my mom
had to sell the house so the first thing
I want you to know is this not all real
estate makes you money this piece of
real estate right here just got paid 19
million maybe 20 million bucks to build
this house he's gonna sell it for 16
million dollars okay I come here I used
the damn place for 2 or 3 weeks pay the
guy 150 or 300 grand for two weeks or
three weeks that we stay here and I walk
away okay
he gets income from one person or eight
people a year eight people nine people
maybe ten people a year maybe twelve
people maybe he rents it every week but
he won't do that every year cause if it
doesn't snow he won't rent it
don't buy single-family homes when
somebody's not in it you got to make the
paycheck you got to pay the check okay
when I rent when I buy a hundred units
or forty units or thirty units okay my
first deal was 38 units I never had less
than 34 those 38 units rented never did
I have less than 34 out of the 38 units
rented which was enough money to pay the
pay the the the note at the bank to pay
for the roof to be fixed to pay the
paint the tenants termites the toilets
the classified ads the problems some of
my mama told me one day she's like you
don't want to get in real estate people
gonna be calling you at midnight I'm
like I wish somebody would call me I've
been busting my ass my whole damn life
so somebody would call me goddamn if
somebody would call me that means
they're paying me see all these homes
right
this guy got 15 million bucks in this
house that's not an investment that's
dead money that's dumb money okay
that's some rich dude him and his wife
found the house oh my god we love this
place and they built it they got money
to throw away okay doesn't mean it's a
good deal a good deal is this pays you
every month the banks don't pay you
every month your stocks don't pay you
every month get investments that pay you
every month between does not pay you
every month is not freedom it does not
provide you with financial freedom it
does not provide you with with financial
freedom of worry I don't want to worry
it's too much drama in life already man
the last thing I want to do is worry
about the damn money okay so my advice
to you is this get involved in
income-producing cashflow positive real
estate don't build it buy it don't build
it buy it stay away from the government
leave the government section eight
programs alone they're nothing but
problems your first purchase should be
at least 16 units preferably 32 and
you'll have to look at a hundred deals
you'll have to look at a hundred deals
to find - that makes sense today okay
then you go to the bank you get a loan
for seventy five sixty five to seventy
five percent of the purchase price let's
say you found 32 units cost you three
million dollars you put 800 grand down
and bar 2.4 million dollars and you're
gonna keep that bad boy for the next 10
or 15 or 20 years and you're gonna
double it triple your money if you don't
know how to do it this makes sense to
you made sense to me man I read all
those books about all the Taikan type
tycoons the JP Morgan's the Rockefellers
they all ended up a real estate funny
thing is all the real estate they owned
produced income all of it okay
Ray Kroc Ray Kroc Pleo McDonald's was
not the hamburgers wasn't the recipes it
was the real estate control the real
estate you control the income then you
got the cash flow and cash flow cash
flow is the Holy Grail
it is the Holy Grail Amazon is the cash
flow company okay Netflix cash flow
company cash flow companies will always
be more valuable than those
produced cash flow rule number two don't
make dumb purchases this car right here
this rolls-royce Wraith with freaking
magic the magic astrological zodiac sign
built into the ceiling with little
sparkles dumbest damn thing you could
ever buy in your life is a big expensive
luxury car in fact okay in my rant today
I want to share with you one of the
things that I did smart in my life was I
never bought these exotic cars that
everybody seems to go out and buy as
soon as they make a little money what I
did was this I waited I waited and I
waited to ever do a dumb thing like this
nothing one of the dumbest things ever
got in my damn life
okay I waited until number one I didn't
have to buy one and number two until it
didn't matter I just got my financial
statement in three months the first
three months of this year compared to
last year a double a double you
understand what a double is a double
means I can do stupid okay
look once you make enough money to where
you can blow four hundred sixty one
thousand dollars and it don't matter
then go do it okay until then until then
do not waste your money I'm sorry this
car was only three hundred eighty four
thousand dollars I didn't want to
exaggerate to you but I think they added
some stuff to this bad boy so look until
then until then until then don't waste
your money on watches and cars and bring
out Briony suits okay it's ridiculous
you guys that are buying twelve hundred
dollar shoes stupid you guys are buying
two hundred thousand dollar cars stupid
you guys that are spending money on
homes no offense but just stupid you
don't need an expensive house you don't
need a country club yet what you need is
paper you need money baby
you need network you need passive income
you need flows baby flows and flows and
flows you don't need a Rolls Royce rule
number three get into multifamily real
estate my dad taught me as a little kid
son if you want freedom if you want
financial freedom you can work or you
can buy real estate okay that building
right there I don't know if you can see
it without my hands getting in the shot
well you probably can't see it see that
apartment building Camden the Camden
group owns that property okay they own I
don't know 50 60 70 thousand apartments
I've been so inspired by real estate my
whole life I'll show you another deal
right here okay here's another apartment
deal over here now I'll tell you why I
like apartments better than this Bank
even though I'm buying this deal right
now because I live my office here
Berkshire Hathaway's a tenant here
Northern Trust is attendant here in so
am I
this building because I can actually
make sense of it now I'm not here to
talk to you about what I'm buying today
I'm here to talk to you about the real
estate game and why it works and why
that apartment building right there is a
better deal than that Bank deal okay let
me tell you why because for the next 30
years I believe this with every penny I
have saved America will become a renter
nation it will become impossible more
and more impossible and more and more
unnecessary for people to buy homes than
ever in my lifetime so inside this
company inside this building right here
where I have four companies that we're
making sales every day we have four
sales organizations here we sell online
platforms work with some of the largest
companies in the world to help their
sales team we consult companies for
their growth all the money that comes
out of those company ends up getting
invested in multifamily real estate
takes a team to do this deal so let me
tell you something it takes a team to
find a deal
it takes reading report after report
after report this is the southeast
multifamily advisory group Cushman
Wakefield
there's Cushman there's CBRE there's HFF
I mean like I was so overwhelmed with
this in the beginning I couldn't even
get a broker to return my phone call to
teach me the game to look at a piece of
property okay this is a property I
bought in Daphne Alabama 344 units it
probably took me 50 phone calls to get
the one guy on the phone to be a bidder
in the deal and I had to look at a
hundred deals times that to even get
this deal in my pipeline so that brought
me back to the three problems I had
three problems you're gonna have and how
I can help you okay number one finding
the deal number two finding a deal
number three taking care of that deal
it's a lot of work okay if you can
figure out how to do those three things
I promise you for the next 15 20 30
years in America multifamily real estate
is gonna boom
and rule number four the last time
before a very special bonus clip is go
big number one rule Warren Buffett says
his look don't lose money number two
rule
don't forget number one rule number
three rule I'm gonna tell you number
three rule don't ever lose money dude
number four rule you got to get invested
at some point you got to get invested
you guys to their 401k retirement
accounts s steps
you got a sitting there dead money
sitting in banks you got a bunch of
money sitting stock market get the money
out of there put it in some produces
income not one home how about five
hundred homes sitting on one piece of
property
if people pay for look like when you're
playing in the snow work playing with
your kids when you invest in money you
need to be careful you need to know what
you're doing
and then once you know what you're doing
once you're going down that hill you
need to go down that hill and find the
edge that's what we do we find big deals
in great locations we take a lot of time
to find the deal and once we do dude I
move fast I move fast and I move hard
you better have a good legal team a good
accounting team a good team behind you
better have you know the brokers in the
marketplace people better take you
seriously and by the way you didn't
close the deal yet
okay hey what's the beauty of this big
icicle right here oh look at that huh
big Oh big baby go big go big what you a
sickles go big on your trips go big in
your business go big we're real estate
now I've got a special grant cardone
bonus clip on how you must invest in
real estate but before that I want to
know what did you learn from this video
what was a single most important lesson
that you're gonna apply to your
investment strategy leave it down the
comments below I want to hear from you
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love see you soon and
enjoy the bonus clip
work hard
even the things I didn't want to do
in real estate income
non-speculative
- [ __ ]
ladies 25
these are wealthy people either there
they keep investing
that's what apartments - that's what
often filled
I'm in the right location
desirable today
with a great place to live
that's how all these people
were started in real estate
for their money
third-most or something
work hard for the money that I've
accumulated
it is a single only thing that separates
me from other people that have worked
hard and found the right
and hard assets that appreciate over
time and
and then when you waste a little money
we can
we can buy stuff big that goes down in
with assets that live
but when we give you the one $1 one was
long media the most important work ever
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
Apple that would be like a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details
[Music]